hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to cover ssris and as always
whenever you get done watching this
youtube video you can access the free
quiz that will test you on this content
so let's get started ssris are selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors and this
group of medications inhibit the
reuptake of the neurotransmitter
serotonin so whenever you're studying
medications many times if you just
simply look at the name of the drug it's
going to tell you how they work in the
body so we know that these drugs inhibit
the reuptake of serotonin and whenever
we talk about the mechanism of action
here in a moment that's going to make a
lot more sense but because they do that
they increase the serotonin levels in
the brain which is helpful for many
patients who are experiencing like
depression so ssris are a common
antidepressant that are prescribed also
they can treat anxiety slash panic
disorders along with compulsion
disorders and ptsd now as a nurse how
can you recognize on a patient's
medication list that they are taking an
ssri well you can look at the generic
name and some of the generic names will
have similar endings some will not but
there's only about six to seven main
ones used here in the u.s and they
include paroxetine and fluoxetine which
if you look at the ending of those they
are very similar and then we have
fluvoxamine and then sertaline and then
there's cetalopram and escitalopram
which are very similar in their names
and then lastly is valazidone now let's
talk about the mechanism of action of
ssris and how they work in our body to
influence the serotonin levels in our
brain so the whole goal of these
medications is to actually block the
reuptake of serotonin by the releasing
neuron now we want serotonin levels to
be balanced we don't want them too low
because that could lead to depression
sleep problems etc and we don't want
them too high because that could lead to
serotonin syndrome which we're going to
talk about a little bit later
so we've already established the
beginning of this lecture that ssris are
used as an antidepressant to treat
patients who are depressed and there's
many theories about what causes
depression one of the theories is that
there's issues with an imbalance of
neurotransmitters and one of those
neurotransmitters being serotonin so if
we can balance that out maybe we can
help a patient with depression so to
really help us understand how ssris work
we have to review neurons and
neurotransmitters so what are neurons
well neurons are the functional part of
our brain without a working neuron our
brain ceases to really function because
neurons are responsible for sending and
transmitting information to either other
neurons or glands or muscles and here
we're going to be talking about
communication between a neuron and a
neuron
now in order to send that message that
neuron has to have some help through a
neurotransmitter and neurotransmitters
are chemical agents they are really what
gives the details of that message that
is being sent and you have many
different types of neurotransmitters in
your body you have some
neurotransmitters that send exciting
messages so they're excitatory
neurotransmitters and this they will
stimulate the brain you have some that
send inhibitory messages which will help
calm the brain and this is what
serotonin is serotonin is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter then you can have
neurotransmitters that can have both
properties so let's talk about serotonin
because that's what we really care about
for this lecture so serotonin helps you
feel calm it is known for giving you
happiness now serotonin receptors are
mainly found in the brain stem
specifically the rafi nucleus and the
neurotransmitter serotonin has a major
influence on your body for instance it
plays a role with your mood it gives you
that ability to feel happy and gives you
mental stability along with your
emotions how you respond to things and
your memory and your sleeping schedule
your appetite and your digestion
therefore in order for us to function
properly we have to have this balance of
serotonin so now let's look at these
serotonin receptors and how they work to
release the neurotransmitter serotonin
and what happens whenever an ssri is on
board and how it actually affects this
process
so here we have a presynaptic neuron
this is going to be the neuron that
actually releases the neurotransmitter
serotonin and that is represented here
with the purple triangles
then we have the postsynaptic neuron and
this is the neuron that is going to have
the special receptors on it that's going
to allow the serotonin to lock onto
those receptors and it will help carry
out that inhibitory message and the
space found between
the presynaptic and the postsynaptic
neuron is known as the synaptic clef so
that's just like a fancy word to say the
space between the two neurons
so whenever the presynaptic neuron
receives its signal it is going to
release serotonin serotonin is going to
enter into the synaptic cleft and then
it's going to go down and it's going to
find its special receptor site on this
postsynaptic neuron
now your body doesn't like anything to
go to waste so in this space the
synaptic cleft there will be some
leftover serotonin so either some of
that will degrade or it will enter back
into this presynaptic neuron for future
use so in order to get back into that
neuron it needs some help and it gets
its help through a special protein
transporter called cert
so some of the serotonin that's been
left over in this space will just
migrate up and go back into this
pre-synaptic neuron and then later on
it'll be ucm
but let's say a patient is taking an
ssri
what's going to happen is this ssri is
going to block this cert from working
the special protein and instead
the serotonin will hang out in this
space longer which will enhance its
availability to these receptors in hope
of enhancing the serotonin levels that
we need for let's say the patient who's
depressed who has low serotonin levels
now let's talk about nursing
responsibilities patient education and
those other important things we need to
know about ssris and help guide us with
those main concepts let's remember the
mnemonic ssris
the first s is symptoms start to improve
around a month to six weeks so you want
to take time to educate the patient that
these medications start to work over
time they don't work instantly because
they have to build up in the system and
to not stop taking them because you
think they're not working and if you do
start experiencing side effects they
will usually start to ease off after
this time so as a nurse you want to
assess the patient's baseline signs and
symptoms and then go back and re
evaluate the patient signs and symptoms
and see if this medication is providing
them relief the next s is slowly taper
off with assistance of the prescriber so
you want to educate the patient that
they don't want to suddenly just quit
taking the ssri sometimes patients feel
better and they don't want to take the
medication anymore and others don't like
the side effects so they may just quit
taking the medication but instead it has
to be tapered off and why is this
because the body is used to that
specific amount of neurotransmitter and
the body must slowly be readjusted to
the change so what can develop is
discontinuation syndrome and this can
last for a week or so and be very
uncomfortable for the patient so what
are some signs and symptoms that your
patient may be going through this well
remember the word stop because they've
just stopped the medication so s is for
stomach pain with diarrhea nausea gi
symptoms will definitely be presenting t
for trouble sleeping
o for off balance they'll be dizzy
experiencing ataxia and then p for
peculiar sensations like they may report
electrical shocks or tingling or
numbness sensations in their body nexus
are for risk for suicidal thoughts in
young adults and possible adverse
effects in pregnancy and breastfeeding
and this depends on the ssri so as a
nurse you want to assess the patient for
thoughts of suicide or self-harm and if
they plan on having a baby if they're
pregnant because some ssris have been
associated with heart defects and a
condition called persistent pulmonary
hypertension of the newborn and then
also if your patient is breastfeeding
assess that as well next is eye
interaction with other medications so
ssris are known to interact with some
over-the-counter medications and
prescription medications so one thing
you want to remember with this is
serotonin syndrome and this occurs when
serotonin levels are too high and it
typically happens when a patient is
taking an ssri and combines it with
another type of medication or substance
that also increases serotonin levels in
the brain so educate the patient to
avoid the following medications mao eyes
which are monoamine oxidase inhibitors
certain opioid medications which are
used for pain
over-the-counter cold medications such
as dextromethorphan which is known as
robitussin alcohol migraine medications
specifically the triptans and then st
john's wort which is an over-the-counter
herbal substance now this condition can
present with the following signs and
symptoms so to help you keep those signs
and symptoms straight let's remember the
word serotonin and we're talking about
high serotonin so s is for sweating
they'll be extremely sweaty and
shivering e is for elevated temperature
and heart rate r rigidity of muscles
o for overactive reflexes t for tremors
slash twitching seizures oh ophthalmolic
changes like pupil dilation in nausea
and vomiting diarrhea i irritability
confusion in for nervousness and anxiety
and then lastly you want to be familiar
with the side effects of ssris and these
are the main side effects that patients
experience and again they tend to ease
off over time so some things that they
can experience is like gi disturbances
because remember whenever we talked
about the role of serotonin it played a
role with our gi system so they can have
nausea and vomiting nausea is a really
big thing so maybe to help provide
relief they can take their medication
with food that might help it also
patients have reported experiencing low
libido or erectile dysfunction along
with weight gain
insomnia so if your patient reports to
you i'm having insomnia i can't sleep at
night because again serotonin is
responsible for helping us with her
whole sleep schedule um you may can
recommend that the patient take the
medication in the morning but let's say
the patient maybe gets drowsy well they
may want to take it at bedtime so just
assess how the patient is tolerating it
with that also the medications can cause
dry mouth so you can recommend that the
patient choose sugarless gum and because
they are experiencing dry mouth they
need to have good dental care so make
sure they're brushing their teeth at
least twice a day and go into regular
dental visits okay so that wraps up this
review over ssris and don't forget to
access the free quiz that will test you
on this material